are you in the mood to watch something
featuring wayward astronauts robots on
the fritz or cursed filled murder
investigations well you're in luck
because the films of 2021 have exactly
that and more to offer you keep watching
to discover 2021's best sci-fi movies
stowaway is an existentially fraught
sci-fi drama that was released on
netflix back in april the plot sends
three astronauts to mars on a two-year
mission and then throws a major wrench
into their plans when a stowaway is
discovered on board director joe penna
has assembled a great cast tony collette
plays the ship's leader on her final
journey in space anna kendrick is the
medical researcher and daniel day kim is
the ship's biologist unbeknownst to them
in unwitting injured stowaway played by
shamir anderson is also on board and
whatever caused his predicament has also
damaged the ship's life support controls
leaving enough oxygen for only three
people one must go or they all die so
the question is who takes that final
spacewalk variety's owen glebermann had
high praise as he declared pena takes a
mission to mars and unfurls it on a
direct and intimate emotional level we
always feel the characters could be us
meanwhile christy lemire of
rogerebert.com called it a clever take
on a familiar genre with a terrific cast
so if you're in the mood for a sci-fi
flick that'll challenge you
philosophically and make you wonder what
you would do in a life-threatening
situation then you better check out
stowaway
the mitchells versus the machines is a
kid-friendly animated adventure that hit
netflix on april 30th it features the
voices of abby jacobson danny mcbride
maya rudolph and michael rienda who also
directed and co-wrote they play a family
on a road trip that turns into an
apocalyptic fight against a robotic
revolution the emphasis on technology as
villain grounds the film squarely in
sci-fi territory as the mitchells are
thrust into a cellphone war after
they've set aside their gadgets for an
old-fashioned vacation the mitchells
versus the machines was a hit with
critics and it was also produced by the
high power team of phil lord and
christopher miller bob strauss of the
san francisco chronicle called it a
machine apocalypse for the whole family
meanwhile the guardian's benjamin lee
noted rianda makes an earnest stab at
trying to offer up a balanced view of
the pros and cons of iphone culture
rather than the easier and clumsier film
he could have made scolding kids for
swiping and tapping and missing out on
real life he shows that young digital
creators are achieving incredible things
and that when used right this form of
connectedness can be a powerful force
oxygen the latest from director
alexander ajah is being hailed as a
taught engaging thriller in this french
language film a woman named liz wakes up
in a cryogenic pod with no knowledge of
who or where she is her only companion
is an ai who advises her that the oxygen
levels of the pot are decreasing at
alarming levels if liz can't figure out
what's going on fast enough she'll
suffocate aja is best known for creature
features like piranha 3d and crawl but
this time around he's earning praise for
his restraint filmed during covet
lockdown oxygen eschews his usual
viscera for more existential dread as
david rooney of the hollywood reporter
declared while cult followers of aja's
extreme horror might be let down by his
turn toward more measured sci-fi there's
plenty of creepy unease packed into his
execution of a simple scenario that
grows increasingly complicated special
praise must all be given to lead actress
melanie laurent in a movie that's
totally focused on one person you need
an emotional powerhouse performance and
that's what she delivers
a quiet place part 2 is the long-awaited
sequel to the 2018 original that had its
theatrical exclusive release on may 28
2021. this creepy sci-fi flick was
quickly certified fresh at rotten
tomatoes earning praise from critics and
audiences alike director screenwriter
star john krasinski's continuation of
the abbott family story provides a
glimpse of the first day that the sonic
aliens arrived krasinski's real-life
wife emily blunt returns his mom evelyn
who journeys with her newborn infant and
two older children in search of a new
place to live after their farm becomes
uninhabitable they eventually come
across killian murphy's emmet a friendly
acquaintance briefly seen in the opening
events of the film alas emmett is now
withdrawn and sullen and our heroes
don't know if they can trust him but
they need his help a quiet place part 2
has earned praise for its superior use
of tension and its tight script the
performances are incredible across the
board with bloody disgusting's megan
navarro lavishing specific praise on
deaf actress millicent simmons by
declaring this is above all simmons show
and she nails it if you were worried
whether or not the sequel would live up
to the first film you can rest assured
that it's another scary silent treat
[Music]
chinese taiwanese sci-fi mystery flick
the soul arrived on netflix on april
14th it doesn't have a lot of reviews in
the u.s but it's nevertheless hitting a
chord with audiences set in a near
future when cars hum with electricity
and holograms pop out of buildings the
soul tells the story of a prosecutor who
has cancer and whose detective wife is
newly pregnant despite his illness they
work together to solve the murder of a
tycoon was it his young wife who killed
him or his alienated son or his partner
who's invented a way to revive dying
neurons with a special powder or is it
the result of a curse that his first
wife placed on him before she died the
story focuses on the interactions of the
characters amidst the sci-fi and occult
trappings daniel hart of ready steady
cuts declared this is a real well-woven
mystery that wants to provoke the
audience with thoughts rather than
events which makes it even more
fascinating meanwhile jk suja of common
sense media opined this film has slick
production strong acting and an
intricate plot quite simply the central
mystery in the soul is captivating
ryan reynolds is the inimitable star of
free guy which arrived in theaters back
in august he plays a guy named guy who
spends every single day greeting his
goldfish drinking coffee and going to
his job at the bank where he talks with
his best friend security guard buddy
played by lil rel howery but guy has no
idea that he's stuck in a predetermined
loop as a non-player character in a
popular video game that is until he
meets molotov girl aka millie and
becomes enamored with her millie played
by jody comer wants to prove that
powerful video game impresario antoine
stole the game that she developed with
her friend keys can guy help millie get
proof before antoine destroys the game
as well as guy buddy and all their npc
friends since its release free guy has
been earning raves from critics
charlotte o'sullivan of the standard for
one praised its humor as she said it's
knowing rather than nasty and even at
its most surreal avoids coming across as
indulgent meanwhile usa today's brian
truett called it a big warm hug of a
movie with plenty to love and robert
daniels of the playlist declared simply
free guy is a winner is that a glock in
your pocket no what it's two clocks
director james gunn delivered his take
on dc super villains in 2021 with the
suicide squad less a sequel to 2016's
suicide squad and more a reboot the film
brings back harley quinn amanda waller
captain boomerang and rick flagg while
adding a whole slew of new characters
including the likes of bloodsport
peacemaker ratcatcher 2 polka dot man
and king shark and that's just barely
scratching the surface once again waller
offers a ragtag group of supervillains
the chance to shave time off their
prison sentences by completing a secret
mission for her if they go off script
she'll blow off their heads what follows
is a lot of mayhem a lot of swearing and
a lot of gory fun the seattle times is
soren anderson raved gun masterfully
mixes humor and bloodshed and manages to
give a surprising number of characters
room to develop their personas and when
it comes to staging set pieces he's at
his best megan navarro of bloody
disgusting concurred as she wrote it's
endearingly sweet even as it's spilling
brain matter and gore by the bucket load
[Music]
filmed on an iphone during the covet 19
lockdown british film infinitum subject
unknown features themes both timely and
timeless written by married couple
matthew and tori butler heart and
directed by matthew it stars tori as
jane an amnesiac woman trapped in a
parallel world and a time loop the film
features cameos from sir ian mckellen
and conleth hill of game of thrones both
of whom may have information that could
help jane regain her memory and return
to her own world before time runs out
infinidum's subject unknown has been
praised specifically for torrey's
performance rachel harper at sci-fi now
for one wrote she shoulders the
responsibility of being alone on screen
incredibly well while carrie o'shea of
warped perspective raved butler heart
pitches her acting perfectly given the
situation's unfolding around her and she
does most of it without saying anything
the film is notable for how it tackles
its heavy and horrific themes in a
surreal and unique manner so if you're
looking for a sci-fi flick that's more
on the intense side of things then
definitely add infinitum subject unknown
to your watch list frank herbert's 1965
novel dune has long been considered
unfilmable but people keep trying there
was the 1984 david lynch version
followed by the 2000 tv miniseries and
now its latest cinematic incarnation is
a sumptuous feast for the eyes and ears
director denis villeneuve wisely
presents only a portion of the source
material in a way that's both satisfying
as a movie in itself and as an
introduction of the events to come it's
the year 10 191 and house of trades is
tasked by the emperor to replace the
ruthless harkonnens as overseers of the
planet arrakis harvesting the plants
coveted spice and keeping an eye on the
fremen the indigenous population whom
the harkinans brutally oppressed the
harkonins are less than pleased and
conflict ensues audiences and critics
alike have fallen in love with dune
salon's melanie mcfarland called it a
gorgeous sensory immersion that holds us
in its spell for hours with an ending
that sparks yearning to see what comes
next the houston chronicles carrie
darling raved dune is an impressive feat
a plunge into a richly designed world
that feels at once ancient and
futuristic and the av club's ignati
vishnovetsky noted that although the
story may feel inconclusive as is the
resulting film is a rarity among the
overlong fx heavy blockbusters of the
last decade one actually wishes it
didn't have to end so soon june is very
rich it's an adventure movie it's a
coming-of-age movie
a basic meaning of true friendship tale
gets a digital upgrade in the animated
feature ron's gone wrong lonely barney
voiced by jack dylan grazer gets his
very own bee bot named ron voiced by
zach galifianakis bee bots are
advertised as kid's best friend out of
the box that connects to all their
favorite apps what could possibly go
wrong well ron could go wrong barney's
father and grandmother can't afford the
expensive companion but they luck into
one that's literally fallen off a truck
the damage from the fall causes ron to
act unlike any other bee bot which soon
comes to the attention of bubble the
company that sells them bubbles ceo
andrew isn't pleased and it's not long
before bubble is after ron to destroy
him while its box office receipts
haven't been great ron's gone wrong has
impressed almost everyone who bought a
ticket to see it angie han at the
hollywood reporter noted what it lacks
and daring imagination it makes up for
with endearing good humor thoughtful
cultural critique and one heck of a cute
robot and the washington post's pat
padua praised the film's family appeal
noting ron's gone wrong has plenty of
slapstick and potty humor for kids but
adults will also be intrigued by its
frequently scathing albeit somewhat
conflicted critique of consumerism
simply put you'll be wrong if you don't
check out ron's gone wrong
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]